si je fais cette vidéo aujourd'hui c'est
reparti pour vous demander de supporter
financièrement le projet tournesol
tournesol qui est une association à but
non lucrative qui propose en gros une
alternative démocratique à l'algorithme
de YouTube malheureusement l'association
ne reçoit pas suffisamment de dons à
leur actuel pour continuer à payer le
salaire de son unique développeur j'en
reparlerai en fin de vidéo
le 29 octobre 2018 un vol domestique en
Indonésie de Jakarta à Cancale Pinang
connu une fin tragique le Boeing 737 MAX
ses choix dans la mer de Java 13 minutes
après décollage les 189 passagers et
l'équipage sont morts lors du crash il
s'agit de l'un des accidents les plus
mortels de l'aviation moderne parmi les
principales causes de cet accident
identifié par les agences de sécurité
dans les semaines qui suivent il y a
notamment un capteur d'angle d'incidence
qui avait la malencontrose propriété
d'être un point de défaillance unique
autrement dit si c'est unique capteur
dysfonctionne le nouveau système
d'augmentation des caractéristiques de
manœuvre ou MKS introduite pour
stabiliser le nouveau modèle du Boeing
737 MAX peut faire tout à coup un
contrablement piqué l'avion et ainsi
conduire à un crash terrible le mois
suivant en décembre 2018
l'administration américaine fédérale de
l'aviation regretta sa décision de 2016
ou elle avait approuvé le nouveau MKS du
Boeing 737 MAX est reconnu en privé que
celui-ci risquait de causer près tous
les deux ans malheureusement seulement 5
mois plus tard le 10 mars 2019 un autre
Boeing 737 MAX opérant Dadis à Baba en
Éthiopie vers narrobie au Kenya connu un
sort similaire avec un crash six minutes
après décollage faisant cette fois 157
victimes le MK semblait à nouveau avoir
été fautif trois jours plus tard
l'administration américaine fédérale de
l'aviation prit la décision d'interdire
tout vol du Boeing 737 MAX une procédure
d'audit inédite fut initiée impliquant
de nombreuses agences comme le
département des transports américains le
Bureau fédéral des investigations aussi
appelé FBI le Conseil national de la
sécurité du transport américain le
bureau de l'Inspection générale des
États-Unis et des groupes de travail
spécialisés et ses investigations
révélèrent bien d'autres défauts encore
y compris des défauts qui n'avaient rien
à voir avec le MKS mais aussi un
gravement que de documentation et un
refus volontaire de former les pilotes
et même des failles dans les ordinateurs
de bord autre fait marquant l'A
illustration américaine fédérale de
l'aviation imposa une amende d'un
million de dollars notamment pour
pression excessive sur les inspecteurs
de la part de Boeing l'interdiction de
vol durera 20 mois et fut accompagné
d'amande dont le total est estimé à 20
milliards de dollars avec en plus des
coûts indirectsimés à plus de 60
milliards de dollars suite notamment aux
annulations de commande des clients de
Boeing le grave manquement de Boeing à
la sécurité mais aussi celui des
régulateurs en premier lieu
l'administration américaine fédérale de
l'aviation aura coûté une énorme fortune
à l'entreprise en plus de 346 vies
humaines et des détresse des proches des
victimes vu les risques il semble clair
qu'il faut exiger de Boeing qui dépense
au moins des milliards de dollars par an
pour garantir autant que possible la
sécurité de leurs avions mais il semble
qu'il faille de surcroît exiger des
agences de sécurité de l'aviation
notamment
celle en Europe qui ont moins de
conflits d'intérêts nationalistes
qu'elles disposent des moyens suffisants
pour faire leur travail d'inspection
avec rigueur malheureusement en croire
notamment cette excellente documentaire
on est encore très loin d'avoir des
budgets et des moyens légaux suffisants
pour imposer la sécurité dans l'aviation
si la sécurité dans le domaine de
l'aviation n'est peut-être pas encore
suffisante il faut tout de même
reconnaître qu'elle semble beaucoup plus
avancée que dans d'autres domaines comme
la sécurité routière la sécurité
financière ou encore et surtout la
sécurité informatique en particulier des
procédures lourdes et coûteuses doivent
être suivies par tout constructeur
d'avions pour certifier la sécurité de
leurs produits ainsi à travers le monde
on trouve de nombreuses agences de
régulation comme l'administration
américaine fédérale de l'aviation
l'agence de l'Union européenne pour la
sécurité aérienne l'administration
d'aviation civile en Chine et d'autres
et pour obtenir un certificat de type
nécessaire pour ensuite commercialiser
un avion les constructeurs doivent
dépenser des millions de dollars voire
des centaines de millions de dollars
quand il s'agit d'avion commerciaux par
ailleurs quand il s'agit d'aviation et
de sécurité la fiabilité de l'avion même
est loin d'être le seul enjeu d'ailleurs
si vous cherchez aircraft security sur
doc go sans doute suite à l'attentat du
11 septembre beaucoup des images que
vous obtiendrez correspondent en fait
davantage à la sécurité d'un vol
vis-à-vis de passagers malveillants
autrement dit dans le domaine de
l'aviation la sécurité c'est aussi et
surtout la sécurité contre les
utilisateurs malveillants il serait
catastrophique si tout utilisateur
pouvait prendre le contrôle de l'avion
et décider de sa gouverne or cette
sécurité est aussi extrêmement coûteuse
elle nécessite l'emploi d'un grand
nombre de ressources humaines pour
contrôler l'absence d'armes légère dans
les affaires des utilisateurs et
entretient ainsi toute une industrie de
la sécurité des aéroports enfin on peut
faire la remarque que cette sécurité est
aussi très encombrante pour les
passagers qui doivent ainsi y venir très
en avance par rapport à l'heure du
décollage surtout dans le cadre des vols
internationaux mais peut-être parce que
les manquements à la sécurité dans
l'aviation conduisent à des images
spectaculaires et à des investigations
journalistiques incessantes et parce
qu'ils attirent naturellement la
curiosité du grand public la sécurité
dans l'av iation est prise très au
sérieux par tous par les aéroports les
passagers les journalistes les
régulateurs et les politiques voire même
si ce n'est pas visiblement toujours
leur top priorité par les concepteurs
des avions même
malheureusement la sécurité de
l'information et des algorithmes qui
maîtrisent tant le flux de l'information
dans le monde ne dispose absolument pas
de la même attention en tout cas jusque
là pourtant comme je n'ai cessé de le
répéter dans cette série de vidéos les
algorithmes les plus influents du web en
particulier les algorithmes de
recommandations sont beaucoup beaucoup
plus dangereux que les avions défectueux
de Boeing pire encore à l'instar d'un
avion piloté par des passagers
clandestins les algorithmes de
recommandation sont aujourd'hui
constamment manipulées par des campagnes
de désinformation organisées qui vont
typiquement abuser d’armée de faux
comptes et de trolls pour amplifier les
contenus qui sont mandatés d'amplifier
et pour réduire au silence l'information
qu'ils veulent noyer je suspecte ainsi
les story killers qui dénoncent cette
industrie de la désinformation d'avoir
été eux-mêmes qu'ils de par ses
campagnes qui ont probablement
massivement signalés ces contenus sur
les réseaux sociaux pour que les
algorithmes croient qu'il s'agit de
désinformation ou de contenu
s'approprier les défaillances de ces
algorithmes du web devraient être
beaucoup plus inquiétante que les
déférences des algorithmes des Boeing
737 MAX après tout même si il s'agit
déjà de tragédie graves les crashs des
Boeing 737 MAX donc finalement provoqué
que je mets bien sûr d'énormes
guillemets sur le que 346 vitres
humaines c'est bien sûr déjà beaucoup
trop mais c'est très négligeable devant
les dizaines de milliers de victimes du
génocide des Rohingya au Myanmar voire
devant le demi-million de morts du
génocide des tigrés en Éthiopie deux cas
où les appels à la haine à la violence
au meurtre et aux jeunes aussi
par les algorithmes de réseaux sociaux
ce qui a fait dire notamment à Amnesty
internationale que ces algorithmes ont
contribué à ces génocides des salariés
disaient qu'ils avaient conscience et
connaissances de l'impact sur les droits
humains que pouvait avoir leurs
algorithmes et leur modèle de
développement et pour autant il ne s'est
rien passé donc ils ont plutôt
privilégié en tout cas mis en avant la
solution de la modération de contenu
alors qu'on sait que c'est assez limité
l'algorithme de modération de contenu ne
repère qu'un petit pourcentage des
contenus haineux alors même que le vrai
problème ça reste l'algorithme qui va
façonner ce qu'on va voir en ligne donc
là en l'occurrence avec avec ce qui
s'est passé au Myanmar on a pu analyser
avec ce rapport de manière assez fine le
rôle de méta et on a pu conclure qu'on
était au deuxième niveau cercle
entreprise a contribué aux atrocités
commises en 2017 et de ce fait elle a
l'obligation au regard du droit
international de verser des réparations
c'est pas la première fois que kamesti
interpelle l'entreprise on avait déjà
publié en 2019 un rapport qui parlait
justement de ce modèle de développement
économique de Facebook à l'époque et de
Google puisque c'est pas le seul géant
du numérique à utiliser ce modèle de
développement notamment pour demander
l'interdiction de la publicité ciblée en
ligne on a de plus en plus une
compréhension effectivement de la
manière dont les algorithmes
fonctionnent mais c'est encore très
opaque pas c'est pas du tout transparent
et il faut absolument pouvoir réguler
les activités de ces grandes plateformes
en ligne et pour le coup les états aussi
ont une responsabilité puisque ce sont
pas des entreprises qui ont l'habitude
de s'auto réguler à cela s'ajoute tous
les troubles de santé mentale y compris
les suicides qui représenteraient plus
de 700000 morts par an selon
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé si
les algorithmes de recommandation
notamment sur Instagram augmente ce
nombre de quelques pourcents seulement
alors on parlerait déjà de dizaines de
milliers de morts et bien sûr ma liste
de victimes collatérales des algorithmes
de recommandation est loin d'être
exhaustive on pourrait par exemple aussi
parler de la désinformation sanitaires
qu'il s'agisse d'amplifier l'hésitation
vaccinale pendant le covid ou de la
promotion massive de pseudo-médecine qui
mettent des vies en danger le plus
préoccupant pour moi c'est surtout
l'amplification massive de la haine en
favorisant les contenus qui a appellent
parfois à la violence voire meurtre les
algorithmes de recommandation mettent en
danger les populations déjà surexposées
à la haine à l'instar de population sont
musulmanes en Inde y compris lorsque ces
derniers n’utilisent pas les réseaux
sociaux autrement dit ça ne sert à rien
de dire un million des droits humains de
cesser d'utiliser les réseaux sociaux ou
un réseau social en particulier sa vie
sera menacée par Facebook que cette
personne utilise Facebook ou non toute
protection de la population mondiale
semble initablement nécessiter une
sécurité beaucoup plus accrue des
systèmes qui maîtrisent le plus le flux
de l'information à travers le monde
malheureusement de nos jours la sécurité
de ces systèmes informationnels est une
énorme mute news surtout en comparaison
des enjeux c'est simple le métier
d'inspecteur des algorithmes de Tik Tok
n'existent essentiellement pas
aujourd'hui et le peu qu'on sait bien
sûr tout d’enquête journalistique à
partir de données publiques ou de fuite
de documents internes mais on est
extrêmement loin du jour ou plusieurs
organismes indépendants de centaines
d'employés chacun chercheront à étudier
les risques de manipulation
d'information en fouillant dans les
codes et les documentations de Google et
et s'il existe il disposent de budgets
extrêmement limités qui les empêchent
complètement de surveiller les milliards
de publicités que Google et Facebook
diffusent chaque année et par exemple
d’évaluer la légalité de ces publicités
comme l’explique si bien l'avocat Albert
Fox Ken sur
lastitutions
Youtube
non seulement les moyens légaux
nécessaires pour auditer ces groupes
sont insuffisants mais surtout les
moyens financiers pour embaucher les
armées d'avocats mais aussi de
chercheurs d'ingénieurs et de
journalistes pour disséquer les IA les
plus puissantes du monde moderne et en
comprendre les vulnérabilités ces moyens
financiers indispensables sont
aujourd'hui cruellement déficients
aujourd'hui les meilleurs avocats
chercheurs et ingénieurs posent pour
Google et compagnie pas pour la
régulation de ces groupes maison ne
pourra pas y couper réguler des marchés
planétaires et dangereux coûtent très
cher il faut de l'argent pour la
régulation il faut de l'argent pour
faire appliquer même des lois déjà
existantes à titre de comparaison
Wikipédia s'appuie sur la Wikimédia
Foundation dont les dépenses sont de
l'ordre de 150 millions de dollars par
an sans de telles investissements le Far
West de l'IA surtout maintenant avec les
algorithmes de langage comme chaque GPT
va inéluctablement perdurer et on risque
de continuer à assister à des
amplifications toujours plus massives de
la haine sur les réseaux sociaux à
l'intérieur des démocraties voire entre
superpuissance internationale il y a
urgence vraiment urgence une époque où
la guerre est revenue en Europe et où
les gouvernements russes et chinois
semblent vouloir faire front commun
contre les démocratie et une aire où le
changement climatique et les inégalités
de richesse service gravement une
période de l'histoire où la haine est
redevenue omniprésente il semble plus
urgent que jamais de se donner les
moyens de vérifier que Google Facebook
Tik Tok et d'autres prennent vraiment
soin de la sécurité de leurs
utilisateurs et de la population
générale et qui ne soit pas en train de
semer les graines d'un futur dystopique
comme vous le savez certainement depuis
bientôt trois ans des amis et moi
travaillant sur une solution pour une
gouvernance collaborative des
algorithmes les plus influents du web à
savoir la plateforme tournesol nous
arrive ainsi régulièrement de passer des
dizaines d'heures dans une semaine sur
notre temps libre à essayer d'améliorer
notre plateforme à concevoir de nouveaux
algorithmes sécurisés à étudier les
garanties mathématiques de ces
algorithmes promouvoir la plateforme sur
les réseaux sociaux à établir des
collaborations avec des entreprises des
institutions et des associations à
écrire des demandes de financement à
expliquer le projet à des étudiants des
journalistes et des chercheurs répondre
aux interrogations de nos utilisateurs à
encadrer des stagiaires et des étudiants
à remplir des documents administratifs
pour la légalité des opérations de
l'association à accompagner les
développeurs bénévoles du code à
ré-estimer les besoins de notre
association à but non lucratif et à
corriger notre vision à long terme du
projet entre autres le travail qui a été
fourni par l'équipe largement bénévole
de tournesol est énorme et alors quand
on a commencé j'étais chercheur à l'EPFL
ce qui fait que mon travail de jour
était parfaitement aligné avec les défis
de conception d'algorithmes et l'étude
mathématiques de ces algorithmes qui
sont absolument nécessaires au
développement d'une plateforme sécurisée
comme tournesol et ça ça fait que en
pratique je travaille à l'époque bien 50
heures par semaine sur différents
aspects tous pertinents à tournesol on
avait alors aussi la chance d'avoir un
ingénieur de recherche payé par le PFL
qui lui passait son temps de travail sur
le développement de tournesol à ça
s'ajoute mais nombreux collaborateurs de
recherche à l'EPFL qui du coup
travaillaient indirectement sur des
mathématiques et des algorithmes
importants pour tournesol cependant
l'été dernier le partenariat avec le PFL
n'a pas été reconduit et nous avons
ainsi perdu d'énormes ressources
humaines pour tournesol en parallèle
notre association tournesol avait
embauché un autre développeur qui lui
travaille à 80% sur le développement de
notre plateforme pour le financer les
co-fondateurs de l'association et des
bénévoles engagés nous avons mis
beaucoup de notre propre argent
cependant cette situation est loin
d'être tenable notamment parce que
depuis je me lance dans un projet de
startup appelé quel CARPA et qui propose
notamment du consulting en cybersécurité
du machine learning mais du coup je n'ai
plus de salaire fixe à injecter dans
tournesol bref pour pouvoir continuer à
payer notre excellent développeur et
ainsi garantir la pérennité du
développement de tournesol il nous
faudra recevoir autour de 3000 euros de
dons mensuels pour l'instant on est à
800 euros ce qui fait qu'on a déjà fait
un quart de chemin mais il reste encore
les trois quarts du chemin à parcourir
et j'aimerais vraiment pouvoir compter
sur vous pour l'accomplir en particulier
si 500 personnes parmi vous décides de
faire un don mensuel de 5 euros
l'association pourra continuer à
développer sereinement la plateforme
tournesol vous serez extrêmement
reconnaissant si vous vouliez bien nous
faire un don unique ou récurrent via
YouTube via un virement bancaire ou via
Paypal pour permettre aux projets et
garder également son indépendance cela
fait 7 ans que je fais des vidéos
gratuitement sur Youtube et
contrairement à mes collègues à part
leur des six premiers mois de la chaîne
je ne vous ai jamais demandé de me faire
des dons en fait ma page tipee demandait
explicitement de ne pas me faire de dons
et je n'ai jamais monétisé mes vidéos si
je vous demande de contribuer ce n'est
absolument pas pour mon propre intérêt
direct je suis personnellement terrifié
par de sécurité des réseaux sociaux et
des algorithmes de recommandation et je
pense que la seule façon de combattre la
désinformation et les appels à la haine
à grande échelle c'est qu'il y ait des
investissements massifs pour les
combattre et les remplacer par des
contenus d'intérêts publics alors bien
sûr c'est pas avec un seul unique
développeur pour ton seul qu'on va
réussir à complètement changer la donne
sur l'état des algorithmes
recommandations aujourd'hui mais faute
de mieux il me semble urgent de
commencer par aider là où on peut
essayer d'encourager le plus de gens
possible en faire de même sachant que de
surcroît tournesol est la seule solution
avancée pour gouverner collaborativement
les algorithmes les plus influents du
web pour autant que je sache et je parle
là en tant que chercheur expert du
domaine et sachant qu'en plus tournesol
est une solution open source sous
licence AGPL libre investir des
ressources humaines dans tournesol me
semble être l'une des meilleures façons
d'avancer aujourd'hui et de sécuriser à
long terme l'information la plus
propagée à travers le monde
bien sûr plutôt que vient un don vous
pouvez aussi nous aider en promouvant
tournesol autour de vous auprès de vos
proches auprès de votre entreprise
auprès de vos amis ou en contribuant à
l'identification de contenu d'intérêt
public via tournesol en comparant si
possible régulièrement des vidéos
YouTube via tournesol mieux encore pour
les plus motivés d'entre vous vous
pourriez nous aider à identifier des
pistes prometteuses de financement voire
à écrire avec nous les demandes de
financement du fond du cœur et au nom de
toute l'équipe de tournesol je vous en
remercie profondément d'avance